[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100 dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia y aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
hay preocupación en el continente
africano ante el aumento de casos de
kobe de 19 organizaciones mundial de la
salud alertó sobre un incremento de los
contagios superiores al 50% sólo en las
últimas semanas
también preocupa el lento avance de las
campañas de vacunación que llegan apenas
al 1% de la población por eso a
sudáfrica se alista para producir
vacunas en el país y acelerar el alcance
poblacional del parque y cada 28 de
junio se conmemora el día del orgullo
lgtb tumbas y el continente africano la
homosexualidad sigue siendo catalogada
como un delito en varios países mientras
que nosotros persiste la discriminación
tenemos reportes desde marruecos y desde
egipto
iniciamos entonces con la información in
africa siete días porque la organización
mundial de la salud alertó sobre un
incremento de los contagios y muertes
por coronavirus durante las últimas
semanas los positivos confirmados
aumentaron en un 52% y las muertes en un
32% esto mientras las campañas de
vacunación han alcanzado apenas al 1% de
la población y varias naciones han
suspendido dichas campañas por falta de
dosis países como uganda imponen nuevas
restricciones
la pandemia de coronavirus sigue
cobrando fuerza y debilitando a un
sistema de salud ya precario en tres
semanas el número de contagios diarios
en uganda aumentó de 100 a 1700 en este
hospital de kampala la atención es
palpable
las reservas de oxígeno que necesitan
nuestros pacientes pronto serán
insuficientes hoy podemos atender a 200
personas
william making pero cada día llegan más
y en algún momento no seremos capaces de
cubrir la demanda
con las 900 camas que tenemos en este
hospital
ante el aumento de los contagios el
gobierno impondrá nuevas medidas de
restricción sanitaria están prohibidos
los viajes al interior del país y el
toque de queda nocturno se prolongará al
menos seis semanas más
uganda como el resto del continente
africano ha visto un veloz incremento de
los contagios
en áfrica que es de sado increased by
fit y en áfrica los casos han aumentado
en un 52% en la última semana y las
muertes han aumentado en un 32% por
ahora sólo se espera que la situación
empeore se ha vacunado menos del 1 por
ciento de la población africana
los mil millones de vacunas prometidas
por los miembros del g7 a los países más
pobres empezarán a entregarse sólo a
partir de septiembre
pues justamente la lentitud en la
vacunación in africa no había provocado
una situación crítica hasta la fecha sin
embargo la aparición de la variante
india delta está llevando al continente
a un colapso que no había vivido en olas
anteriores esto coincide con un gran
escepticismo frente a la vacunación
después de que la mayoría de ciudadanos
africanos inoculados con kobe cell no
estén autorizados a entrar a territorio
europeo nos informa luis muñoz
poco más del 1 por ciento de la
población de áfrica ha sido vacunada
hasta hace unas semanas la inoculación
no era una emergencia para la mayoría de
países de áfrica es el continente menos
afectado por la pandemia después de
oceanía la clave había sido una
población joven que vive principalmente
en la calle sin embargo el aumento de
casos derivados de variantes como la
delta india están despertando todas las
alertas igual que los demás países de
áfrica sudáfrica está experimentando un
resurgimiento masivo de infecciones se
espera que el récord de casos lleguen
tres semanas al continente además de las
variantes y la lentitud en la
inoculación agrava la situación la
llegada del invierno en el hemisferio
sur la solución para combatir el aumento
son las vacunas
no estamos ganando la batalla contra el
virus en áfrica no me importa en este
momento que las vacunas sean de kóvacs o
de cualquier otra parte necesitamos un
acceso rápido a cualquier solución los
líderes del g-7 prometieron donar mil
millones de dosis a los países más
pobres y sin embargo la distribución
está siendo demasiado lenta también la
gestión interna en los países africanos
con fallas logísticas que están
provocando que las dosis caduquen pero a
los rebrotes ya la falta de acceso a las
vacunas se suma el bloqueo para los
ciudadanos africanos el uso mayoritario
de comisión la vacuna desarrollada por
oxford y astrazéneca pero fabricada en
institutos erum de india provoca que los
africanos no puedan acceder a europa al
no haber sido autorizada por la agencia
europea de medicamentos en infusión y la
imposición de estos requisitos para la
vacunación en el mundo dan como
resultado una doble desigualdad los que
no tienen acceso a las vacunas no
tendrán la oportunidad de viajar
mientras espera que la unión europea
valide covisal muchos africanos están
optando por no vacunarse dudando de la
viabilidad de la solución pese a su
reconocimiento por parte de la
organización mundial de la salud
entretanto las autoridades en sudáfrica
anunciaron nuevas restricciones durante
14 días en un nuevo intento por contener
el aumento de los casos de kobe 19 pero
además del anuncio dieron a conocer sus
avances en la primera etapa para
producir vacunas en su territorio el
proyecto busca suministrar al continente
africano una mejor capacidad de
distribución del medicamento
vacunar a los sudafricanos con dosis
fabricadas en su propio territorio esa
es la ambición del gobierno de cyril
ramaphosa las autoridades con el apoyo
de la ms quieren establecer un centro de
transferencia de tecnología para las
vacunas de adn mensajero antich hoy
sería el primero de este tipo en suelo
africano estos centros de transferencia
de tecnología son lugares de
capacitación donde los fabricantes de
países de ingresos bajos y medios pueden
recibir capacitación sobre cómo producir
ciertas vacunas y las licencias
correspondientes para hacerlo en la
actualidad sólo el 2% de la población
africana ha recibido al menos una dosis
de una vacuna contra el coronavirus
mientras que eeuu y europa se acercan al
50% sudáfrica también representa más del
35 por ciento de los casos registrados
de ccoo y 19 en áfrica mientras que las
dosis prometidas por el programa kóvacs
están disminuyendo
en boxes
simplemente no podemos seguir
dependiendo de las vacunas fabricadas
fuera de áfrica porque nunca llegan
nunca llegan a tiempo y la gente sigue
muriendo por eso pedimos el
levantamiento de la patente pero también
la transferencia de tecnología esto
sería un paso increíble de fenómenos
ramaphosa ha hecho campaña activamente
para el levantamiento temporal de las
patentes de las vacunas y se ha
convertido en un duro crítico de la
desigualdad en el acceso a ellas si todo
va según lo planeado
sudáfrica podría fabricar vacunas en un
plazo de 9 a 12 meses según la ms y
cambiamos de información porque el
gobierno de etiopía dio a conocer que
aceptó una solicitud de alto al fuego
por unilateral e inmediato en las
regiones del tigre esto después de que
los grupos armados rebeldes anunciaran
que retomaron el control de meckel en la
capital regional y de que el gobierno
local nombrado por el primer ministro
había que saliera de la ciudad el
conflicto en la región ha generado una
grave crisis humanitaria con miles de
desplazados y desabastecimiento de
alimentos
cada 28 de junio se celebra a nivel
mundial el día de la diversidad sexual
también conocido como el pride el día
del orgullo lgtb tucumán se trata de una
conmemoración dedicada a generar
conciencia acerca de los retos que
enfrentan las personas de este colectivo
las cuales siguen siendo objeto de
violaciones a sus derechos humanos en
marruecos la homosexualidad sigue siendo
considerada como un delito al igual que
en otros países del continente desde
marrakech nos informó nuestra
corresponsal sofía català aquí en
marruecos la homosexualidad se castiga
hasta con tres años de cárcel y este
marco legal propicia cierta
normalización hacia las agresiones
contra la comunidad lgtb y fue sanado el
caso de una influencer que en pleno
confinamiento en 2020 incitó a sus
seguidores a trapear usuarios en las
redes sociales de la comunidad lgtb y
para desvelar sus identidades en
facebook pero por otra parte también
existe un creciente movimiento social
muy fuerte en las redes que defiende los
derechos de la comunidad lgtb y más allá
también ha tomado mucha fuerza en la
plataforma fuera de la ley que exige la
derogación de todas las leyes morales
del código penal que prohíben
hasta el sexo fuera del matrimonio la
homosexualidad entre otras cuestiones
fundamentales y cuyo incumplimiento
lleva a la cárcel a miles de personas
cada año y por otra parte cabe tener en
cuenta que aunque muchos discursos
oficiales atribuyen estas leyes morales
al islam religión de estado en marruecos
lo cierto es que datan del código
napoleónico del siglo 19 impuesto
durante la colonización francesa y
plasmado en la constitución tras la
independencia del país y aunque no en
todos los países africanos ser
homosexual bisexual o transgénero es un
delito en la mayoría de ellos persiste
la persecución y la discriminación
contra estas personas desde el cairo la
capital de egipto nos ampliaron está
corresponsal nuria test ahora si
hablamos de retos para la comunidad lgtb
y en egipto está absolutamente todo por
hacer no hay ninguna ley que lo prohíba
específicamente pero sí hay muchas leyes
que hablan de inmoralidad o de atentar
contra los derechos de la familia y es
precisamente de esas leyes de las que se
vale la autoridad egipcia para reprimir
a todos aquellos individuos que forman
parte de esa comunidad o se atreven a
querer y sentir diferente el ejemplo más
claro hace cuatro años
el concierto del grupo libanés más rue
leila en el que algunos jóvenes egipcios
decidieron esgrimir una bandera arcoiris
y reivindicar su sexualidad muchos
acabaron detenidos y entre ellos hará
giras y una activista y escritora
egipcia lesbiana que pasó tres meses en
la cárcel siendo torturada y abusada
tiempo después ya en el exilio acabaría
su vida con una carta en la cual
perdonaba y se convertiría no solamente
en un símbolo dentro del país sino
dentro de la comunidad internacional de
esa lucha en la que todavía queda tanto
por hacer en los derechos y libertades
de la comunidad lgtbi y finalizamos este
capítulo de aplica siete días con música
que nos llega desde colombia donde los
artistas jóvenes afro colombianos se
unieron para presentar una canción muy
diferente se trata del rapero antioqueño
bombee quien se unió a la chocoana
maryland reconocida por la academia de
la grabación grammy como una de las
artistas lg y con más latinas que el
mundo debe conocer juntos presentan esta
colaboración titulada diferente desde
medellín en bom vinos con todos los
detalles
qué es lo que aunque es lo que mi gente
aquí en ley del corriente bomba quiero
enviarle un saludo bien especial a toda
la gente de frank 24 y en especial este
programa que es áfrica siete días hoy
vengo a presentar diferente con milán en
el cual quisimos dejar que la gente
empiece a ver que nos podemos salir de
lo cotidiano partamos de algo desde que
todas las personas somos diferentes
cierto entonces cuando empecemos a
respetar las diferencias de los demás
cuando empecemos a abrazar las
diferencias de los demás el mundo va a
ser mucho mejor aquí en esto podemos
encontrar todo este pacific biden style
que es como llega a la música urbana al
pacífico colombiano con todo este a
provida con todo este reggaetón con todo
esto es que a propongo que quisimos
mezclar aquí no solamente auditivamente
sino estéticamente así lo pueden
encontrar en en mi canal de youtube el
vídeo diferente pueden escucharlo en la
plataforma de sus grados y vayan
pónganse y el modo de que si aceptamos y
respetamos las diferencias de las
personas todo a ser mucho más chévere
así que le mando un saludo muchas
gracias por el espacio esto que se llama
diferente
y menos del frente 20 dímelo de frente
día y con esta buena música finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días
ustedes también pueden continuar con más
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ampliar la información de américa
latina y el mundo quédense con nosotros
esto es trans 24
dímelo de frente lo que digan de mí no
lo creas miente
yo quiero que te vengas aquí con mis
puntos junto a mí en mi casa me junto a
lo diferente
verdad
[Música]
i